on ouvre une page transport à présent
l'avenir de l'aéroport de tours
s'obscurcit un peu plus après ce coup de
théâtre hier soir au conseil
métropolitan le maire de tours a
démissionné de la présidence du smad est
le syndicat qui gère l'aéroport
l'écologiste est en désaccord avec ses
collègues sur la stratégie de
développement de l'infrastructure eux
dénoncent une capitulation
alors que l'avenir de l'aéroport se joue
dès maintenant explications de florent
clavel l'aéroport de tours en pleine
turbulence les avions toujours cloués au
sol pour cause de qu'ovide voici
maintenant la crise politique après la
démission du maire de tours de la
présidence du smad est c'est l'avenir
proche de l'aéroport qui est engagé
selon frédéric augis fin connaisseur du
dossier
on était sur un compte à rebours le fait
de passer militaire et civil il ya un
certain nombre de certifications qu'il
faut obtenir là le fait qu'il ait
démissionné
il faut que la métropole nomme quelqu'un
d'autre que le syndicat se réunissent et
puisse redonner un président ça nous
emmène à février quelconque en train de
perdre trois mois qui sont des mois
capitaux pour l'avenir de l'aéroport
au coeur de cette démission la volonté
des manuels denis de supprimer deux
lignes celle de marrakech et celle de
marseille
impensable pour une partie des élus de
la métropole qui pointait un nouveau
coup porté à l'aéroport emmanuel denis
lui se justifie compte tenu du trafic et
de la crise économique
il était de bon aloi de réduire le
trafic pour faire des économies sur les
subventions à ryanair et donc obtenir
une dsp qui soit à coût neutre malgré la
tempête la métropole a voté hier soir 3
millions d'euros sur les neuf nécessaire
à des travaux et des aménagements le
département et la région doivent
compléter pour pérenniser l'aéroport à
région centre val de loire ne peut pas
envisager d'être sans sa aéroports alors
qu'elle est un
vrai pôle de développement économique et
de recherche alors qu'elle est un vrai
pôle de développement touristique et
pour cela c'est un nouveau défi qui
attend les élus attirer de nouvelles
compagnies aériennes autre que l'actuel
ryanair pas simple alors que le secteur
aérien et durablement fragilisée par le
cos vite 19